what did we give this crowd and why
haven't we been giving to the crowds the
last 13 [ __ ] years
no that's a wonderful thank you I think
I know why you're happy it's spring it's
the first day of spring or as we say
here in California the last day of hope
for rain were screwed that's really
that's a tough one but look all the news
is from that other desert in the world
the Middle East a lot of news out of
there this week shocking election in
Israel you saw that Netanyahu has
returned to power and the day before the
day before the election he said there
will never be a Palestinian state on my
watch and the day after the election he
said I'd like to see a two-state
solution it was such an amazing 180 Mitt
Romney went wow that guy's good
now of course many people can point out
that a one-state solution for Israel is
very dangerous because this is a country
after all where the Arab boat and it is
almost half Arab and they asked
Netanyahu today what about that did he
have any message for Israeli Jews and he
said yeah keep [ __ ] get in there man
now the Republicans are mad at President
Obama cuz he did not call Prime Minister
Netanyahu right away he did finally the
other day and he said that we're gonna
have to reassess our options with this
for you
you're right we're gonna stop stop
dating Israel and we're gonna we're
gonna get together with Syria now that's
gonna be our new girlfriend I mean could
we have a little perspective is anyone
here up for a little perspective on this
because this week in Saudi Arabia they
sentenced a woman to 70 lashes not
tongue lashes actual lashes for the
crime of arguing with a man and Isis
took a break from throwing gay people
off the roof and burning pilots alive
and beheading people to blow up two
mosque in Yemen and a museum in Tunisia
and I have to tell you when I heard that
they blew up a museum my first thought
was thank God no Americans were hurt
the quiz the buffet in a waterslide yes
it would have been a disaster here in
America meanwhile John Boehner has
announced that he will be visiting
Israel he will be traveling under his
Secret Service nickname Agent Orange and
oh I'm looking forward to that trip I
would just like to say to the Israelis
if you think you've heard wailing at the
Wailing Wall
wait'll old super soaker
cuz it couldn't cry when he should face
there that's gonna be something painter
refers to is realized the land of milk
and Kahlua
he's another tough week for Republicans
it pains me but
they lost one of their rising stars in
Illinois congressman Aaron Schock had to
resolve there's Aaron yes there yeah
yeah isn't that what you want your
Congressman to do work on his abs yeah
but he had to resign because apparently
he was spending taxpayer money like it's
going out of style and speaking of going
out of style
he literally spent $100,000 of taxpayer
money to redecorate his office in the
style of Downton Abbey and he once took
a private jet on taxpayer dollars to see
a Bears game and that's always been the
word on Washington about Aaron Schock he
loves the Bears but apparently the last
row was that he asked to be reimbursed
by again the government for taxpayer
money four hundred and seventy thousand
miles on his car but when he sold his
car it only had 80,000 miles on it
and when they confronted him with this
he just went up I resigned was it
seriously
and today Robert Durst said dude I cut a
guy into 10 pieces and got off you can't
explain 90,000 miles
yeah man HBO caught a murder atop that
Netflix to do did you watch that
documentary I miss was fascinating stuff
their ability to be able to capture
Durst in those rare moments when he
wasn't killing someone and and they
arrested him this week in New Orleans
not a minute too soon it looks like he
was planning to flee he had with him 40
grand in cash a gun and five ounces of
pot so it was either gonna make a run
for it or produce a hip-hop album I
don't know
as I'm sure you know one of the victims
was here in LA so the trial will be here
another celebrity trial here in LA which
means he will definitely get off even
though as you saw they have him on a hot
mic saying the words there it is I'm
caught what did I do
killed them all of course but his
already his lawyers were already
explaining this away they said when he
said you're caught he was in the urinal
he meant his dick in the zipper I killed
them all the cigarette butts in there I
killed them all
and finally did you see this I thought
this is really interesting Starbucks the
CEO of Starbucks in this year they says
he wants is his baristas there to
initiate a conversation about race with
the customers and I think Bravo but
pleased not before I've had my coffee
you